[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du 7-8 loisirs
vos idées sorties dans le département on
commence ensuite avec le sommaire les
fêtes de fin d'année approchent et c'est
le moment de penser aux repas ce
week-end plaire anime des ateliers
cuisine à plaisir nous leur recevront en
plateau pour parler de ses prochains
pour sur la thématique du réveillon la
belle au bois dormant le chef-d'oeuvre
de la danse classique de tchaikovsky
reprend vie sur la scène du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le jakobson
ballet de saint pétersbourg et
interprète sous dalle est incontournable
en forme et l'ani poker nous parlera
danse contemporaine avec un spectacle
interactif à la ferme du bel ébat pop-up
garden fait participer les enfants
découverte dans ses magazines
noël approche et c'est le moment de
décorer sa maison pour accueillir
dignement le père noël à guyancourt
l'espace yves montand propose des
ateliers ce samedi de 14h à 18h florence
coquard vous apprendra à réaliser un
mémo de noël et la botte du père noël
on les écoute nous en dire plus elle
était au micro de nicolas d'andré ces
ateliers sont destinés pour les parents
et les enfants
d'accord donc on accepte les enfants
accompagnés d'un parent donc à petites
fables tous
alors on prend pas des tout petits tout
petit apport pour tous ce qu'est mémo au
niveau de la décoration ce qui leur
permet aussi de pouvoir coller peindre
est vraiment personnalisée selon leurs
goûts
jusqu'au 22 décembre ne manquez pas la
deuxième édition du festival disney dû
signer cette d'elancourt la salle
organise trois projections de films la
première ce samedi avec réponse
tous les enfants sont invités à se
déguiser la deuxième sera les
aristochats lundi 19 avec un concours de
karaoké cette fois et pour finir jeudi
22 la petite sirène conclure à ce
festival avec un concours de dessin on
écoute ce luc beaucourt le responsable
du synes est au micro de patrick jacques
de dixmude
c'est un partenariat avec la ville
d'elancourt son école d'arts plastiques
et en fait ça vise à des moments on va
dire de
de festif familiaux de redécouverte
voire de découverte pour les enfants de
vieux disney ya un catalogue disney
héritage donc on pioche dedans tous les
ans avec des lots à gagner
avec à chaque fois distribution de
bonbons la présence du père noël bien
évidemment à peine plus d'une semaine
avant le réveillon et vous ne savez pas
encore ce qu'il y aura au menu où vous
ne lancez vous n'osez pas vous lancer en
cuisine et pourtant la cuisine c'est
facile en tout cas c'est sylvie gameplay
requis en est convaincu elle anime des
ateliers cuisine a plaisir à nous a
rejoint sur le plateau bonjour sylvie on
sera camille alors je vous le disais
enfin je le disais vous êtes donc
cuisinière et professeur depuis quatre
ans dans votre atelier à la cuisine
facile.com et pour les fêtes vous
proposer des cours pour aborder un petit
peu le repas du réveillon
tout à fait alors notamment demain après
midi et lundi après-midi des cours sur
le foie gras ou leur part avec cette
terrine bonnes à manger dans huit jours
et sinon la bûche de au praliné le
vendredi 23 décembre après midi et le
matin des macarons festif au saumon et
au foie gras donc ils y ait de la place
encore donc c'est des ateliers
accessibles à tout doucement vous le
disais donc pour les adultes il ya les
cours sur le foie gras sur les macarons
exercice parfois un peu périlleux quand
on n'est pas encore habitué c'est
peut-être pour ça aussi qu'on a besoin
de cours parfois et sur la bûche praliné
mais les enfants peuvent aussi mettre la
main à la pâte tout à fait son bienvenue
à partir de 8 ans et ils peuvent faire
des très beaux cup cakes des sables et
de noël et ils repartent avec leur
réalisation
pour les savourer en famille alors du
coup votre devise c'est justement la
cuisine c'est facile c'est vraiment
accessible à tous c'est montrer que tout
le monde peut y arriver
quel que soit son niveau au final tout à
fait je pars de souvent de recettes de
grands chefs que je simplifie et moi
cours sont agrémentés de pleins
d'astuces de trucs de conseils pour que
l'on puisse aussi bien acheter les
produits en confiance et après les
et cuisiner et réussir sa recette alors
qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie
justement de vous lancer un petit peu
dans ses cours de cuisine parce qu'au
début vous étiez cuisinière on l'a dit
et qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie de
vous rapprocher justement du public
d'échanger avec lui de transmettre votre
savoir faire un petit peu c'est la
transmission qui est importante en
cuisine et c'est pour ça que j'ai ouvert
cette école parce que j'aime échanger
j'ai me donner des conseils et c'est un
plaisir de rencontrer des gens
totalement différent et qui viennent
d'un peu partout en ile de france aussi
bien petits et grands et on a des cours
du coup vous le disais il ya certaines
datent de cours mais on peut aussi
réserver vous appelez directement est
réservé pour privatiser tout à fait mais
on peut privatiser à partir de trois
personnes et ça peut être en famille ça
pète entre amis et je reçois jusqu'à 8
personnes à l'atelier pour donner un
petit un petit peu les tarifs quand on
veut privatiser un pur
comment ça se passe quand c'est le même
tarif que l'on soit on vient de tout
seul avec d'autres personnes qui l on se
rejoint que en groupe
donc une heure de course et 26 euros
pour un adulte 2 heures 35 euros elle
pendant une heure et demie 35 euros deux
heures à 50 euros
après le foie gras est un petit
supplément et si on veut manger sur
place aussi un petit supplément pour le
vin et le café ça peut faire des idées
de cadeaux de noël pour le père noël
aussi on peut commander un petit bond où
commence à poser beaucoup de faire sept
fons à m'écrire un mail en disant je
voudrais offrir à mon conjoint ou
conjointe mes enfants mes neveux nièces
ou à mes parents des cours de cuisine je
leur envoie un bon cadeau par mail et la
personne choisie pendant un an les cours
qu'elle ait envie de suivre
on va revenir un petit peu sur les sur
des coups que vous proposez justement
aux enfants sur le plateau pour nous
avait amené des petits exemples
alors ça typiquement c'est ce que des
enfants peuvent réaliser qu'est ce que
c'est au moment des sables et de noël
exactement c'est alors là ce sont des
recettes alsacienne et j'ai réalisé ce
matin pour vous et avec des épices de
noël pour les abris en forme des toiles
donc essentiellement à base de cannelle
de poudre d'amandes et de poudre de
noisettes un petit peu riche mais très
très bon et les autres très subtil
puisqu'ils sont à base de vanille
alors combien de temps ce que ça prend
par exemple pour un enfant ce type de
recettes soit trop long peut-être pas
perdre l'attention des enfants pour les
captiver vraiment
jusqu'à la fin alors les cours dure 1h30
ou 2h en pâtisserie avec les enfants
mais je peux vous dire quand ils font
tout de a à z
ils ne sont pas dispersés alors on va
voir un petit peu plus loin parce
qu'après noël et le nouvel an il ya
aussi l'épiphanie et vous proposer de
réaliser sa galette sa galette des rois
maison également c'est exact alors ça
c'est le cours sera programmée en
janvier
et là pendant le cours les personnes
après à faire la pâte feuilletée mais
aussi la garniture à base de pâte
d'amande de poudre d'amande et donc
qu'on appelle la frangipane et repartent
avec leur galette
ban a savouré voilà et du coup vraiment
la cuisine c'est facile mais maintenant
voilà même pendant huit ans un enfant de
8 ans on peut y arriver je l'avais dit
j'ai apprend à se servir très tôt
d'ustensiles qui font parfois peur aux
adultes
que ce soit la poche à douille les
emporte pièce et je leur donne aussi un
petit peu de rigueur il faut pesé au
gramme près quand et en pâtisserie et
sinon on fait travailler aussi son
imagination que ce soit en cuisine
pâtisserie
merci beaucoup sylvie guillem clair si
vous êtes en manque d'idées de noël pour
les repas ou si vous n'osez pas vous
lancer vous pouvez l'appeler vous
pourrez épater vos amis et votre famille
pour les fêtes toutes les dates des
différents ateliers sont à retrouver sur
le site internet où vous pouvez
directement contacter sylvie pour vous
inscrire ou pour plus de renseignements
merci beaucoup c'est lui merci camille
le chorégraphe rudolf noureev parlait de
lui comme du ballet des ballets la belle
au bois dormant revit sur la scène du
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
jusqu'à demain soir
le chef-d'oeuvre de marius plus de
petits pas sur la musique de tchaikovsky
inspiré du conte de charles perrault et
réinterprétés par les danseurs russes du
jakobson ballet nous avons suivi des
répétitions les images de mélanie poquet
on
c'est l'histoire d'une princesse
ensorcelé par une fée malveillantes
à l'aube de ses 16 ans aurore se pique
le doigt et s'endort jusqu'au baiser
d'un prince la belle au bois dormant
un ballet conte de fées revisité par le
chorégraphe français jean guillaume bart
pour moi de cette princesse elle symbole
de de la lumière de la de la jeunesse et
de dunes c'est une promesse de bonheur
finalement et que par ce sortilège cette
promesse de bonheur c'est à et elle se
réveille grâce
effectivement elle a fait lila qui vient
qui va chercher le prince dans un pays
très régulée et tout finit bien le mal
et est vraiment tuée par l'amour composé
de 75 danseurs la troupe du jakobson
ballet de saint pétersbourg redonne vie
aux chefs-d'oeuvre musicale de
tchaïkovski un travail mené depuis
février 2016
il s'inspire du ballet de marius petipa
2890 devenu l'un des plus célèbres de
l'histoire de la danse
[Musique]
on n'a pas été simple finalement de me
détacher de ce que je connaissais par
coeur pour essayer de revenir à des
choses peut-être plus plus traditionnels
notamment dans la tradition russe que
j'ai voulu respecter puisque c'est aussi
avec des danseurs russes que j'ai
travaillé l'école russe est très
expressive notamment dans des ports de
bras dans les dents les expressifs de
l'expression des des épaulements ils ont
ils ont vraiment une qualité de porc de
braque nous n'avons pas dans l'école
française
je pense que c'est
voilà c'est un spectacle idéal pour les
fêtes de fin d'année considéré comme le
ballet des ballets par son caractère
majestueux et raffinée la belle au bois
dormant se déguste comme une gourmandise
un savoureux mélange entre danse et fait
[Musique]
on reste dans l'univers de la danse mais
plus contemporaine cette fois notre
rendez-vous junior est un spectacle pour
et avec des enfants mélanie poker nous a
rejoint pour nous présenter pop-up
garden par jour car ni le titre du
spectacle c'est bien pop gardanne et ça
se déroule en ce moment à la ferme de
bel ébat de guyancourt pendant près
d'une heure c'est un instant poétique
c'est un spectacle en hommage à gilles
clément impôts est paysagiste et
botaniste français mais aussi à tous
ceux qui créent des jardins à partir de
rien sont pas mes mots mais ceux de
david et venturini le directeur
artistique de la compagnie italienne et
tpe se pensent peut être que co basée
sur un petit écolo mais c'est surtout la
relation entre l'art et la nature entre
l art et les jeunes à notre jardin sont
un jardin artistique m'a même aussi en
jardin dans lesquels la relation avec la
nature
c'est plutôt en relation avec la
créativité
alors david et venturini parle d'un
jardin mais dans un jardin bien
particulier particulier parce qu'il n'y
a pas d'herbe pas d'eau pas de fleurs en
tout cas pas de manière réelle c'est un
spectacle interactif des capteurs
analyse les mouvements des danseurs et
du public et évolue avec eux et c'est un
spectacle très ludique de danseurs sont
sur scène et joue avec les éléments de
danseurs pros de danseurs professionnels
mais pas seulement vous le voyez sur les
images il y a des enfants ça arrive au
bout d'une quarantaine de minutes et une
quarantaine d'enfants d'enfants peut
aller alors s'amuser sur scène et faire
réagir les projections animées c'est
mais c'est un spectacle pour tous aussi
écouter bien
j'ai beaucoup aimé la fin la fois ces
termes qui peuvent bien méritée but
[Musique]
et
rapporté que c'est un fils né et avoir
et et là moi qui s'était bien il n'est
bien typés mais pour la fin un petit peu
pas et après apprécié mais tout mais
après tu fais une danse après qu après
je marchais sur l'air au début je
trouvais ça on va dire un petit peu
étrange et en fin de compte ça s'est
révélé super intéressant je pense qu'ils
ont réussi à bien me lis qu'on
n'entendait pas l'effet sonore et
l'effet visuel et la deuxième partie
était super cool pour les enfants alors
pour découvrir pop à gardanne via une
nouvelle représentation le samedi 17
décembre à 18 heures à la ferme de bel
ébat à ne pas manquer donc pour les
enfants qui ne veulent pas être
simplement spectateur mais aussi acteurs
le temps d'une pièce
merci beaucoup de mélanie poquet on
passe maintenant à notre agenda les
autres rendez vous à ne pas manquer pour
la première fois une patinoire
écologique a pris place aux
clayes-sous-bois petits et grands sont
invités à l'inauguration qui a lieu
gratuitement ce soir avec un spectacle
autrement vous pourrez chaussez vos
patins jusqu'au 24 décembre
ce samedi à 20 heures l'association ski
danse organise une soirée dansante en
faveur du téléthon
l'occasion de réviser un peu ses pas de
danse avant les fêtes tout en faisant
une bonne action
c'est la fin de ce set 8 loisirs je vous
laisse je vous remercie de nous avoir
suivis je vous retrouve vendredi
prochain pour le dernier numéro de la
saison 2016 passé un très bon week end
[Musique]